the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention is out with new guidelines
for reopening houses of worship after
the White House ordered revisions it
backs up president Trump's push to have
places of worship open this weekend mr.
Trump has threatened to override
governor's who don't comply although
it's unclear if he has the authority to
do that
there has been pushback from some
religious organizations and even members
of the White House Corona task force
Nikole Killion is at the White House
Nicole good morning good morning to you
Michele and a White House official
confirms that the faith community was
consulted about these guidelines and
some evangelical leaders tell CBS News
they pressed the president to reopen but
other major religious organizations like
the National Council of Churches are
urging extreme caution and say the
process should not be rushed at my
direction the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention is issuing
guidance for communities of faith at a
hastily called news conference Friday
President Trump deemed places of worship
essential some governors have deemed to
liquor stores and abortion clinics as
essential but have left out churches and
other houses of worship it's now right
he implored governor's to open them
right away if they don't do it I will
override the governor's but not long
after the president made the declaration
one of the lead members of his
coronavirus task force suggested this
maybe they can't go this week if there's
high number of Kovach cases maybe they
wait another week the White House
insisted it's not mixed messaging the
president wants to see these communities
open dr. Burks was integral to making
these guidelines and they lay out a
pretty clear path for faith communities
to reopen the CDC guidance which had
been delayed includes recommendations
like using face coverings cleaning and
disinfecting frequently and practicing
social distancing the agency also
suggests holding services in
well-ventilated areas or outdoors
limiting shared items like prayer books
or hymnals and cutting down on choirs
and singing to reduce aerosol
transmission see
goes this first weekend and like a coach
and football will make halftime
adjustments if we have to the White
House is also encouraging Americans to
take other precautions throughout the
Memorial Day weekend you can go out you
can be outside you can play golf you can
go to the beaches if you say six feet
apart but remember that that is your
space and that's a space that you need
to protect dr. Burks said the amount of
illness in the country is decreasing but
she did express caution about several
new metropolitan hotspots including
Washington DC which now has the highest
number of test cases in the country
Michelle we must keep our eyes open
Nicole thank you